*INHALE*
*KAHSNEEZE*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica: Below Zero.
There's been an update to the game
And now that I'm not an idiot and I actually know what the hell I'm doing. I just gotta go find it
What am I seeing?
What is that floating ball sack in the middle of the ocean also my face still
still sWoLeN
but you know getting by
doing good, feeling good, feeling fresh. Just got to get out of here
So somewhere in this great big ocean of ours, there is the plans for some kind of a Sea Truck
Now I don't know where those are
but there's also been some other things updated the game that I don't know because I don't actually read
and if I don't Oh,
Cock ass. What is? Oh, I know what the problem is, Hey
Yeah, there we go. That's probably better. It was probably running like a bag of tits. Okay, so that's that's definitely better
Oh, yeah, that's that's something good. No, it's not. It's not good at all. Um
Let me see something here. I'm gonna troubleshoot for a bit everybody. Hold on what you kidding me? Excuse me
Are you out of your mind? Okay, I gotta stop this
Right, let's try that you piece of shit hi, what you gonna do now? Oh not so bad now, are you just as bad?
Oh, you just bagged a Dick's ain't you?
Oh, you just owe you tip dick and all oh, oh
Oh, you think that I'm just gonna sit by and let you do what you're doing manul
Boom let's go. What are we doing here? What are we doing?
I'll tell you what we're doing we're doing exactly boom this exactly look like a dream like a goddamn dream suddenly like a dream
Oh, yeah, like a dream now all dream baby. Okay. Anyway, I'm probably drowning
Let's poke our head up and see what's going on around here. Whoosh. Hello
Stop that
Could you just there we go
So somewhere in this great big ocean of errors is the plans and we gotta go find it. Look at me in the eye
You know that we have to find it
All we have to do is find the place where it is and then go get it you did is exactly that simple
Hang on I need to troubleshoot a little more. I'm working in the Bois. Oh, fuck. Oh god. Okay. Hang on stop
and
Suddenly we're back. All right now for realsies it had you know, it shouldn't be bag of dick. Why should be bag of dick?
What's it gotta be bag a dick Wyatt Wyatt bag and it hang on I got stuff
Okay, how's it doing now? Is that better? I think that might actually be better. Okay
Did I is it no longer bag of disks dicks? Is it no longer turd basket?
Because if we aren't I'm gonna be very happy, but if we is then I'm gonna be very upset. Hang on. There we go
That's better. Okay, we're all
Mm-hmm me know like you what's going on there
There we go. Smooth as a baby's butt smooth this busy
But baby's bottom don't know why this game is taking so much goddamn GPU to render
Alright now we're gonna get along with the goddamn game. Okay, so there is one
I don't know for certain but there is one spot down in like the Arctic area
No, I don't know if they added any other threats. I literally did not read the changelog because I'm an idiot
I don't pay attention to anything like that
But there is one spot where I remember there being like a dock thing where there could have been
some kind of a you know, little
little bit of a like a like a little bit of a
Data box like a taste box. I don't know. I know sorry for my brain to conjure up
Maybe there's a data box there. Also. I don't know what else they did to the navigation area of this
That's not the right words
But you know the map I don't know what they did to change the map Oh dick and Diddley. Look at this. Oh, never never
Mind loaded in yes. Hey
Let me suck you. I I know it's around here somewhere. I'm gonna pop my head up breathe
inhale deeply I'm gonna inhale various oxygen up here and then I'm gonna smack back down and hope that there's no
Don't tell me what to do Karen, I live my life the way I want to live it Karen
you are not the boss me that is not how marriage works I
See a glow Oh what the fuck is that
What is that what is that? Oh, is that a whale oh my god. Oh my god. I thought those were eyes
Oh my god. I thought those were eyes
Holy shit, I can't ride you now Oh suddenly. I can't ride you. Oh, okay. I see
Oh there I go
Okay, but I got to do is I gotta find jankis and then munches
Yeah my munch, you know man and then I'm gonna find this thing. I don't know exactly where it is
You guys are big protect me
I don't know where it is around here either because it's just dark or maybe I don't know the area but it looks like it's
Changed a bit. Ooh God. Oh god, there's so many of y'all are there's so many of y'all. I'm going too deep
I don't remember it being this deep before it was kind of long the walls edge a little bit, but we're from there
I don't even know
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I'm gonna drown. Yeah
Yeah old news there Taryn. I've drowned many times before I know how to deal with the afterlife bullshit. I was way down there
Oh shit, there's threshers. Hey bud. Oh shit. I may not make it there Karen
Why didn't you warn me sooner why Karen? Why where am I? Oh
Hello. Okay, so somewhere around here somewhere. No nowhere though. I'm but it's somewhere here
Like I'm not too far away from it. It was down towards underneath the eye. Hey
Hey, you know you don't know no, no
There is that it no, but close somewhere down here. Why don't I fucking look it up
Why would I not look up where the see how to get the C truck?
That seems like a good thing and then I wouldn't waste my time. Let's go ahead and fucking you do that
Okay, C truck is a mobile sea bass. Ooh a quick submersible
location deep
Search for it. Oh god kill me kill D
Somebody please eat me alive
Hey you come on. Come on. You want to fight huh? You want to fight? Yeah, I'll go toe-to-toe with you. Huh? Go stalker
I forgot you're a stalker not a not thresher. I don't even know what a thresher EO you're running like a little bitch, baby
Hi, you don't want to go toe-to-toe with me, huh? Oh, yeah coming back for another pass. Oh, wow! Ah
We're going toe-to-toe. We're going we're going to fin to fin
We're gonna nip to knop are you I'm gonna I'm gonna eat your bones. They grabbed one of you no. No you don't
Young kiss come on. You want some of this? I'll take Buffy on Wow. Oh
Shit, you dead? No, you're not dead. Not yet. Anyway, come on
I'm gonna you only kiss you're doing casts to marry you I want to kill you before I drown I'm gonna eat this fish before
I drown it takes it away from me. Oh, that's good. Just good stuff. Come here with my last breath. I stab at thee
I'm just using this as a teleport to get back to my baby
Don't tell nobody I'm exploiting the systems. All right, what did I lose nothing? Cuz I'm a badass. Alright, so somewhere around here
Hey, they filled up. My food bar man. Dying sure is competing. Oh, that's right
I was gonna scan for it because they've got the scanner room and then I can actually look for it with the cameras which are
Faster and can breathe underwater in dummy. All right a
Fragment, okay, here we go. We're gonna look for fragments
Fragment, okay, so we're gonna go for that one first and more will pop up on my interface as soon as they are discovered
Goddamn, I love using technology correctly in this place Oh another one. I'm such a genius
I'm such a smarty. Oh my god. It was right outside my base. Oh
Oh
Brute shark, you ain't so brute. Oh fuck take you incus. Oh
Okay. All right. Maybe I'll kiss skedaddle
Fragment up there fragment down there. I didn't see how many I needed scissors a fragment here. But there's nothing Oh, what is that Oh,
Mobile vehicle but mobile vehicle bay. Okay. I need three of those. Ah
That is handy. Ooh found more. Okay, so it says something's there Oh something is there. Oh, wow. Something is propulsion cannon. Oh hell
Yeah, I might toss some fish around it's works out good for me man. This is stasis rifle. This is my god
I never would have found these I bet these were here before but just didn't see them. Oh, hey, buddy. How you doing?
Friend, don't bite me god. I don't bite me don't do it. Hey, listen, you don't need to do it
No, he's gonna get me. Ooh, sick dodge got that mobile vehicle BAE. This is the last piece for that
All right, so that's that so there was something over here. I just didn't see it in the brush there
It is stasis rifle man. These things are just laid out here. All right got that need to get some o2
And then hopefully I'm gonna find the rest of the actual vehicle itself soon. It's probably up in here
Stop it, man. You don't need to do it. You don't need to do it. Not my cheeks hurt real bad
Everybody give me pity points dies my cheeks hurt real bad
Oh cue the dramatic music I still got my wisdom teeth holes in my face
the only thing that can cure me is for you to like this video, but you know, I
Know
Hey Aquarium module fragment
Okay, I don't know what the aquarium module is for oh
I don't have any batteries. I guess I'm good manual mode now
That actually hurts more than just me not being a bitch where did it go that was
I don't know and it just vanished. Okay, I guess whoa. Whoa
Whoa see monkey, I
What are you you're cute? Oh, you're cute donk. Oh, you're pretty cute. Let me get a look at you. Oh, you are cute Oh
No, I
Will cut you. I'm cutting you. I'm cutting you. I'll cut you. I'm gonna cut you. Okay you
I
Don't like you
I need more battery that son of a bitch thinks being a playful little scamp more like being a playful little
Asshole think you can just take it like that. No. Oh
Oh no, yeah, whatever. Okay. Do I have enough for a battery?
I doubt it was a Power Cell for the truck for the truck. Okay
Do I have any ribbon plants in any of my stored sky fund? Yes, I do. Okay
Do you have are those dead batteries are those those are dead batteries? Okay, so I'm gonna toss those there
let's make us a battery to please actually and then I'm
What the fuck?
What what the fuck what the fuck cuz I can't get more of those but that's fine. Umm
Lilypad resource. I don't care anybody cut copper here copper anybody. No, okay
so one battery is all we're gonna get but one battery's all we're gonna need because then we're gonna switch over the power cells for
The other dudes but we're gonna be better than that, but it doesn't matter if they're empty or not
Hope you guys can understand what I said and if you do it, and I don't care
Hey, I need to clean up the back of my
Okay, I don't know if this is the second or third second
Okay, so we need one more of those and then we need to get the other fragment for the mobile aquarium
Whatever that may be, I don't know why we would need a mobile aquarium. Oh, yes
Yes, please
And then we're just gonna leave
That is not a seed truck. That is a seamoth. I'm it as much as I miss miss- Whoa
as much as I miss bubble, but I think I'm gonna like the Sea Truck a little better kind of like a
Intermediary between the seamoth and a cyclops, which was just a tad unwieldy
I think we did we get enough for the mobile vehicle day. I do not know
No, that's a that's a craftable in this store
I don't know if I have enough for it on my half to go seek some resources, but as it stands
I'm in good position. So let's get right to it
Alright, so I need the mobile vehicle Bay which requires lube, power cell and titanium ingot. I've got some titanium
Here enough for one ingot. No, probably not I need
Ten silicone rubber I think was part of it
I need to get creepvine oil for the I honestly don't have titanium (Oh really mark? You just looked at it.)
But I need to go out and I need to get Copper. Anyways, good thing. I'm over here~. by these~, but none of them have
*Quick Pause* BERRIES!!!
Berry! where berry? Oh, there berry. Okay. Got berry Thank You Barry. Okay, I'm gonna grab these
It's a lot of Lube don't need that much Hey No, are you coppered? Yes, I
Need two more titanium anyway, so this is good
Yep. Okay. That's the last titanium. I'm picking up though copper. Yes, how much room I got nothing? Okay, perfect. Let's get back
Let's make this bad boy. Yoinkus. Yoink my doinkus.
I don't think there's a badass is I think okay, so I got some Lube. Oh one each. Oh cool
Well, I already have silicone rubber and I know I'm gonna need more Lube
I'm gonna need our cell which is two batteries and silicone rubber
All I need to do is take one of the dead batteries out
So I need to make a Power Cell get the titanium ingot which I can make right now
Let's get the dead batteries out and let's make it out of that. Let's put okay. They're all dead
So all these batteries are dead put it in here make a Power Cell and I'm gonna need another Power Cell for the big thing
Anyway, so let's make the mobile vehicle Bay and then whatever it takes for the truck
I'm gonna find out as soon as I deploy this bad boy Geoffrey Billy Sam wose and Marshall are gonna be back
Who are actually gonna be able to say hi to them? Well receive really really really you think really you think oh shit
That didn't I?
Didn't do it. There we go
Hey Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall how y'all doin? Good? Good good
Okay, so we see truck and see aquarium module advanced wiring kit times five lead-glass
Whoa, Oofus my tufus that's a lot of stuff. Okay advanced wiring kit
Advanced wiring kit oof and the Sea Truck aquarium module. Alright. Okay, Geoffrey Billy. Samwise and Marshall. I'll be back
Five Jesus. Okay. I don't even know what it takes to make one
What are we looking at here advanced wiring kit or silver or so?
We're into lost silver a lot of gold and a lot of computer chips. Holy shit. Alright, um fuck well
Nobody ever said it was gonna be easy. I don't know if I have the table quarrel
I definitely don't have the table and I'm definitely gonna search for that. I have to lead exactly - no, that's lithium
That's not even lead. So first off
I got a search for table coral, that's first and silver maybe first I got search for silver
Let's look for breakable silver outcrop
Let's go for that first cuz that's what I need to make just the computer chips, and I need five of those. He's dork
It's very dork
silver
titanium lead a shit breakable silver, man
These are strewn about this is gonna take some search and so cue the montage music
I'm gonna walk up cue the montage music. It's gonna be it's gonna be lit. Hey, I'll double down it's gonna be lit a.m
Fuck
There's some table coral that's good, maybe that shit. Well no no no no no no, no
No, there is no need there is no need. Yeah, there's no need
Whoa. Whoa, there's no need. Hey, dude. I know I got a delicious delectable face, but you there is no need yeesh
Hmm that's unpleasant. Whoa
Inventory is full Oh hot tits. Yeah. All right, so that should be enough to get started
I still don't have enough lead but that's gonna be next on my list. Where's my face? Come on base
Don't do this to me get in my face. So now that I got the silver
I think it's gonna be enough to make I think this is the first of the wiring kit. That's yeah the wiring kits
Okay, so we're gonna make the wiring kits we need five of these. I think we have enough one, two, three four. Yes
Okay, so we got what we need there
Let's go ahead and put some shit away and get rid of that and some of that and that for now not the table
So we need some more table corals. So I got to go search for table Coral none of that. Please give me table coral what?
We're gonna look for lead our eBook this is fucking bullshit. Okay, so I gotta just manually find table coral which I
Tried that before and it didn't go so good
Let that should be enough. Okay, so I need to I need table coral now there that's table coral moderately easier to spot now
I spy with my little eye wha-hoo they warned me. Okay, that should be enough. Oh
That was right by my head. Okay, so I got enough table coral now, I just need to get
Whatever the fuck else. I was gonna get golden copper wire, so I got some copper
I know that and I've got some gold. I know that copper gold. Do I have enough gold I have
Four gold that might not be enough gold might not be enough
I might need one more which I'd be very mad at but I would get I understand whatever
Whatever. It's just gotta be a pain in the dick. All right, so let's make the copper wire for it
You just take one you put it in a taffy machine you stretch it out you got copper wire
How does it take - how long's is wire? Son of bitch? Okay, I have enough table coral. I only need ten
So let's just put this away for now and let's go get some gold
So I got to go deep for that shit and on the way I can get some of the other stuff I need
There we go. Got enough. Okay, that should be everything that I need to make this truck now
I don't know if it's gonna be usable right away
I don't see why I wouldn't be if it would come with a Power Cell and then all I'd have to do is make more
Power Cells which I could do right now
I'm gonna eat you you are fun and dancing and free and I'm going to eat you
Come on you oh you quick. Are you quick? Can I get also get a water bag?
Can I get one of you water bags? Yo you dance and you shouldn't have been dance and you should have been run in
Yeah, I can't believe I can't make water yet
I thought you can do that at the beginning before if you just like make bleach and shit, but apparently not now
Please I need these beepers. I think the peepers give a little water if you eat them if you eat them cooked
Anyway, if you eat them raw, it's somehow for some reason that takes water away
Which doesn't make any sense in a real RP situation that don't make no sense
Well, whatever we're gonna pretend like it's fine. Whatever. I ain't complete. Look at this face. You think this face complaint? No
Absolutely, not. Absolutely not. Okay. I need to get my table coral back out
It should be enough and I need to make these bad boys and there we go
Okay, and that should be five right one two four. I need one more
I like this music
Are you kidding me? I need gold for every single one it ooh
You are
You I need gold for every single one of these advanced wiring kits
I need two gold for each one off. I need nine more
All right. Sure. Yeah, we're gonna go with that. Okay. Yeah, that's great. That's just wonderful. That's wonderful
Let's charging it 1% power left in this thing. I don't even have enough for another battery. I don't have any copper for it
oh you
Know no, that's no good. Okay. All right. I guess I'll go find some more
Sure. Yeah. Okay. We're gonna yeah, sure. Okay. Oh
No copper. Yeah, okay. All right. Okay wink wonk
All right, that'll be enough and some more of those plants if I can grab them
And there she goes she did. Okay, there's a whole string of gold over there. So that's that bodes
Well for me, I mean, I'm not happy about it, but it does bode well for me ooh and more of those plants
Oh, I love it. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I'm sorry Karen. I love you. Oh
I can't even make water. Why can't I make water? I don't know then let me make water
Yeah, I have to get bladder fish for water, which is stupid
That's not that stupid. It's pretty smart actually, okay
So first things first, I gotta go get some bladder fish for water or else I'll die or whatever
That's it real yo you okay? I don't
Die, all right. Yeah, cuz you do die in this game. Uh-huh. Okay. I'll wink long. All right. Well, I guess the oceans have been
Expunged of all bladder fish and I'm going to dehydrate to death, you know
Forget that whole thing that you could last for three days without water
No not here. No never not here. There's no blood
well
This problem. That is a problem
Okay
I don't exactly know to do about that because either I'm crazy or blind or there literally are
No bladder fish, you know, and I'm just gonna grab other fish and suck the juice out of him
I guess it's the best I could do at this point
There's no
Nope. Oh shit. Oh, fuck. Oh shit. I
Made it. Nice made it made
Yeah, oh that was close. But I'm just gonna get if some other fish and suck the juice out of 'em I suppose
It's the best I can do cuz ow
Was that cuz I am drowning or dehydrating really? Oh
I'm bleeding
No wonder work. No wonder I'm losing fluids
I'm bleeding everywhere high in fluids low calorie count. Okay, I guess that's gonna do I
Guess it was high in fluids, but that's hardly helpful. That doesn't help me
That's I'm still gonna eventually die from this shit. Alright. Well, that's a problem
developers
Developers there seems to be an issue. What am I looking at here? What do we get? What are we dealing with?
Titanium exactly what I wanted. Yep so much on my screen. I can't even see what's going on Gold. Yes
I need a lot of gold cue epic montage
music
How many is that? Seven. I need ten. Well, I need nine, but I think I pulled it out of my storage
So I think I definitely do need ten
But if I run out of fluid and then lose the items that I've gathered like if I lose all this gold because I run
Out of fluids and I die. I'm gonna be very upset
let's just try to get the last of the gold and let's try to get in the base because I think if I get in
The base that like saves your inventory just gotta get lucky with the gold. No not gonna lucky with the gold not this time
Yep. Okay. How many is that?
Ten! All right, let's get back. Oh, I'm not gonna make it. I'm gonna run out fluids and then I'mma die
Oh shit bladder fish just don't exist. I don't even know if I can search for something like that
I think I just have to fucking deal. I've been what else am I gonna do? There's no bladder fish out there
There's just not oh
I'm gonna eat too much and that's gonna hurt me
All right, whatever that apparently that worked. Okay, so I need to pull the wiring kits out of here
And then now I can actually make the wiring kits but there was something else I needed titanium ingots. I think I need those
unpowered
You COCK fine
Limestone fucking cock. Oh
There we go, what are we getting power now? Okay. Yes. Sure sure. We are
I guess I'll put this shit back go get some titanium. I guess I shouldn't have passed up all that titanium
I was a fool.
I didn't know what I had. Oh
Now it's gonna give me all the copper in the world yeah now it is okay that's and that makes sense I
Know I know I know there's no Eyeyes. Ooh
That's an Eyeye how many titanium I got.. seven. I think it was wasn't it?
Like two? Didn't I need two? I might have needed two but I'm not sure I'm just gonna make these this into food for water
Any water? There we go. Uh, let's make this into the tide. No. Oh well. All right
That's not what I was hoping for. You. Don't you hate to see it? I have nine
Really? I don't know how many of those I need. I really don't how many do I need Geoffrey Billy Samwise Marshall
Can you tell me again how much I needed?
Hello
eh? *confusion*
Hello, what what?
What what Oh Oh God Oh somehow I under played it
I have no idea how just one. Oh just one then I have enough. I've got everything I need. Okay, this is good
This is good as opposed to it being bad. This is good. Okay, surprisingly shockingly. This is good. Oh, I have everything on me
So I'm good. All right, so let's just make the advanced wiring kits
We need two glass and then bada-bing, bada-boom, Bob's your uncle. We got what we need, SHOCKINGLY
Shockingly look in my eyes. This is a shock to both you and me. I have no idea how this happened
I didn't think I was capable of something as skillful as this and yet here we are
I am just as surprised as you are gonna make the glass and the Power Cell
I do I have the Power Cell on my person
Or did I already make the Power Cell I have no idea. Either wait we have what we need. Let's go. jEfFrEyBiLLySaMwiSeandmArShaLL
I got a job for you. I got a job for you. Oh shit
No
I don't cuz I forgot the lead nevermind
Cut this out cut this part out got this embarrassing part where I forgot something cut it out. Got it right now
We're gonna do this. Oh, yes, baby. Oh, yes, baby
Yes
it slotted pretty under it's not as I'm not as well as I was hoping I'm a little under a
little underwhelmed kind of like a
stumbly little goober there like a tip of a dick. Okay. Well, it's a lot. Yeah, it's not it's
Really less it's really less captivating than I thought. It'd be it is really underwhelming it is
Really underwhelming and I put oh, yeah, it only has one why it looks like it has two, but maybe it doesn't okay
Well, you know, it seems that the aquarium expansion seems to suggest that maybe you could have more. Okay, it's pretty cool. Alright this oh
Yeah, okay, nevermind. You know what this is? Okay. I like this. This is great
I'm super into this. I'm gonna call you the thickness
Cuz you may not be thick right now. What is that? Do I have a camera? Whoa?
What where'd that go? What is that? What am I? What am I looking at? Why is that happening?
I don't know what that is. That's super weird. But okay
Alright, but anyway, so now I have the thickness
It's cuz you may not be thick now, but you are going to grow you're gonna grow thicker. You're gonna grow stronger
You gonna grow longer? Oh, yes. The thickness is real and the thickness will be seen someday
I don't know why that's happening. So you better be down with the thickness because the thickness gonna show you what is up?
So anyway, that is all the time I have for this episode
I'm gonna die of thirst real soon here from the thickness and I will play this again with more
Exploratorium's with the thickness as we go deep down into the dark depths. I have no idea what that's happening
I think it's something to do with the camera, but I think that might be a bug, no idea
Thank you so much for watching. And as always, I will see you in the next video
BUH-BYEYAH!